yeah welcome to this video playing loves
or not zoom ok let's go for French this
knight c6 line the game a variation is
really interesting but I don't know it
in much detail I only watched a bit of
John Watson's video coverage on the ICC
probably already screwed it up not sure
let's say oh wait wait wait wait wait
maybe the other actually and c6 am i
winning a pawn 95 yeah probably i'm i'm
stumbling into some some dangerous line
that i don't know i take it now what is
the problem Queen edge 59 f seven should
be quite big oops really
yeah I cannot take age 70 it's a really
cool decided in one second it probably
is losers straight away but he still
plays it instantly really hard to
believe that this shouldn't lose putting
yourself into a pin okay but let's check
and actually maybe it's not so bad but
it looks very strange to me hmm okay
ok it's got an ID f3 coming up
yeah probably that is no refutation
remarkably
yep okay I mean it isn't a big problem
but I'm just surprised that this is
really am a playable move
quite weird
I'm 35 okay about queen d 6
hmm quite weird
yeah this is the sort of fun escape
hatch that whiter always has here
yeah hopefully at least have some um
Action Center yeah like this this is
nice actually it goes Bishop g6 I just
can go play yeah let's grab space now
yeah not sure maybe I actually miss time
that could be due to quick ok let's see
me there was no need to to push
immediately I could play we should be
six and whatever first maybe we should
be six castles long i can actually
castle long him yeah i don't like it i
advanced to quickly so not not a big
problem but i think i could have got
more of this
it's a good Center
and b6 Bishop f64 this is the kind of
plan i'm thinking of
deform is now looming t43
yeah this is very difficult to defend to
say the least should Bishop to d3 the
defense I defensive IDM
just night five maybe mmmm I'm not sure
can let's do this first it's not bad at
all
yeah I was hoping that this is good
intending attacking this and d3 look
before to get on on the beep on it also
Roxy to don't see how I defends it now
yeah / no way to defend me to Queen a to
our King Air 200 k it like the capture
on v6 didn't really help yeah yeah I did
I was really shocked at Bishop h7 I
really want oops it was too quick let's
look at this I mean okay maybe it's just
a decision if you don't take it's it's
all nonsense like playing g6 next move
and diss epona up maybe on this side on
this account still I thought I'm always
shocked that they play such a committal
move with three seconds okay but it
doesn't seem to to lose anything came
five yeah and this okay this is very
nice end game now but i'm not sure that
II for is really good now I can play and
this is better not move the center so
quickly this is such a great point
Center you should move the bones you
only give away squares just keep like
this end and try long castles and and
pressure on those like a bank Oh
pressuring and now he's backing up yeah
in fact them I'm not quite sure what's
happening here and I can take this
alright thanks for watching